After a failed 2007 film adaptation, Philip
Pullman's inventive His Dark Materials series
is finally set to arrive on HBO in 2019.
If you're ready to see Lyra's journey translated
to the small screen, here are all the details
you need to know before His Dark Materials
premieres.
Philip Pullman's first His Dark Materials
book, published as The Golden Compass in America,
tells the story of Lyra, a young girl who
lives in a world with "daemons," which are
counterparts of a person's soul that take
the form of an animal.
Lyra and her daemon Pantalaimon [pant-uh-LIE-mon]
discover evidence of "Dust," mysterious particles
that are more attracted to children than adults,
leading them on a grand adventure.
Lyra also gains possession of the titular
golden compass, which is technically called
an alethiometer, which can discern the truth
in any situation.
The two continue their journey, eventually
meeting Will, a boy from a different dimension.
As the three journey on in the subsequent
novels, The Subtle Knife and The Amber Spyglass,
they find more universes, make new friends
and enemies, and even "kill God."
That last plot point, unsurprisingly, has
stirred up some controversy since the first
novel was published in 1995.
Pullman, an avowed atheist, has staunchly
defended his series throughout the years,
sticking to his guns about his allegories
and subject matter without hesitation.
Thanks to the popularity of the books, an
adaptation didn't take very long.
In 2007, The Golden Compass arrived in theaters.
One of New Line Cinema's most expensive productions
to date, it underperformed at the North American
box office upon its release.
Despite a talented cast and Academy Award-winning
special effects, the movie failed with audiences
and critics alike.
With plenty of creative unhappiness behind
the scenes and loud dissent from the Catholic
Church, the movie did not get a sequel.
The original Golden Compass film might have
faltered when it came to the plot, but its
casting choices were pretty excellent, leaving
a new cast with big shoes to fill.
Luckily, the new adaptation has recruited
a stacked cast of its own.
James McAvoy will step into Lord Asriel's
calculating and intimidating shoes, and will
spend some time on screen with Luther's Ruth
Wilson, who will be playing the secretly insidious
Mrs. Coulter.
Hamilton creator Lin-Manuel Miranda, who was
last seen on-screen in Mary Poppins Returns,
will take over the role of Lee Scoresby],
the affable aeronaut [AIR-oh-not] who helps
Lyra throughout her journey.
The cast will be rounded out with familiar
faces like Clarke Peters, Ariyon Bakare, and
many more
If you thought there was plenty of starpower
in front of the camera for His Dark Materials,
wait until you hear who's working behind the
scenes.
The series will be written by Jack Thorne,
who cut his teeth on shows like Skins and
Shameless, as well as films like Wonder and
A Long Way Down.
From there, he moved to the stage and, alongside
writer J.K.
Rowling and co-writer John Tiffany, Thorne
wrote the script for the play Harry Potter
and the Cursed Child.
The first two episodes of the series will
have an even bigger Hollywood darling at the
helm.
Academy Award-winning director Tom Hooper,
who won an Oscar for The King's Speech and
followed that up with Les Miserables, will
kick off the series just before his adaptation
of Cats hits the big screen during the 2019
holiday season.
In short, fans of the books can rest assured
that His Dark Materials will have plenty of
talent working behind the scenes.
Of course, one of the most important roles
in the series is that of Lyra, the plucky,
brilliant, and brave heroine who inspired
millions of fans as they made their way through
the original books.
On the heels of Dakota Blue Richards, who
made her film debut with the role in the 2007
film adaptation, it was clear that producers
would need to find a young actress who feels
wise beyond her years.
In March of 2018, it was announced that Dafne
Keen would step into Lyra's formidable shoes.
If that name sounds at all familiar to you,
it's probably because you saw her breakout
role in Logan alongside Hugh Jackman in his
final appearance as Wolverine.
Keen made her mark playing Laura, Logan's
clone daughter in an emotional and grounding
performance that made her an obvious choice
to pick up Lyra's alethiometer for the series.
Naturally, His Dark Materials made its way
to the holy grail of pop culture conventions,
San Diego Comic-Con, in July.
There, a few more details were announced about
the upcoming series to keep fans on their
toes.
Miranda, known for his musical roles, announced
that he'll bring some song and dance to the
show by entering the series with a performance
co-anchored by his daemon.
Wilson, for her part, revealed that the show
delves into Mrs. Coulter's backstory which
should provide new insight for fans.
"Philip Pullman gave us a nice in to dig a
bit deeper into her and see who she is on
her own, with her monkey, without Lyra."
The minds behind the project also assured
audiences that the show wouldn't explicitly
criticize religious institutions, choosing
instead to attack broader authoritarian concepts.
One of the chief complaints about the 2007
adaptation of The Golden Compass was that
the movie tried to keep everything far too
light, with studio executives actively pushing
for a "happy ending" and looking for an upbeat
finale for the first film.
Luckily, according to Pullman, the BBC and
HBO have no such qualms about happy endings.
Pullman has granted his permission for the
books, which rely heavily on Victorian elements,
to be twisted and modernized for the adaptation,
reinventing the story for today's audiences.
For fans who grew up with the books and disliked
the most recent adaptation, they may be able
to rest easy and enjoy a more sophisticated
take on these beloved novels.
We'll have to see what that looks like when
the series arrives some time in Fall 2019.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.